大家好,今天非常感谢一鸣老师能够抽出时间来跟我录制这么一期内容啊,因为一鸣老师的线下课程就是有问的小伙伴非常的多,所以呢我也把大家疑问点比较多的问题今天我都总结出来了,那今天呢也是就是让一鸣老师直接来为咱们做一期专门的课程答疑,那接下来呢我就先把时间交给我们一鸣老师,先给大家伙讲讲我们线下课程大概会具体讲到哪些内容,好吧一鸣老师。
好的,好的有你。
那我开始吧
咱们其实主要是
课程是针对机器学习
在整个量化交易场景下的一个应用
因为之前
我记得也做过一期视频的分享
是专门讲这个从数据到策略的
这个全流程的这个拆解
其实我们整个的课程
也是和那个公开视频上的
这个流程完全是相同的
因为用力说
这个有很多小伙伴
可能有很多问题
所以就专门录制一期
看看大家的这个问题
都统一的解答一下
那我们的这个
主要的上课的地点
其实就是在北京和上海
然后都是由我来
给大家来直接的来讲述
然后课程的优势呢
其实我自己总结了一下
然后还是蛮有竞争力的
那首先呢
我们是首次公开了
这个卡马超过三的
这么一个机器学习模型的
训练的全过程
对也就是说
从整个的这个数据的
这个处理
然后标签
特征到训练到推理到
backtesting到回测
对等等
然后这是一个全过程
因为这个要把整整体的
这个pipe plan给到
大家这个才能有价值
然后其中呢
包括了我们这个
C时间轴的
自定义的这个轴的实现的方式
也就是说我们对这个
整个的这个行情数据进行重采样
然后用到我们自己的这个周期
没有用这个时间轴
因为时间轴本身
它是有很多问题的
完全不具有统计特性
另外每个bar的内部
其实这个信息密度也不是均衡
另外呢
我们还会用到这个机器学习
来进行这个趋势性标签的这个标注
对
那这个呢
是我们可以通过我们自己参数的设定
来做这个不同趋势性的这个标签
对
然后另外呢
就是也是首次公开了
我们的二级模型的训练方式
也就是说我们常提到的这个Meta的这个模型的训练方式
对另外呢
就是说有一些机构的小伙伴
然后之前也是会有疑问
就是说我们如何用整个的Pipeline来提升我们整体的这个管理规模
那在这边呢
也会有一个在课程里面也会有详细的一个讲解
另外呢
就是说我们整个的这个Pipeline的这个代码是全部是给到大家的
然后呢在课程上也也是要整个的
大家要全部的这个跑通
对也是希望大家能够通过这个
pipeline和代码
能够完全实现自主的这个模型训练哈
那这个是我们课程一个想要的一个目
想做到的一个目标
对另外呢就是整体的内容呢
其实分几个部分哈
比如说机器学习基础的讲解
然后因为我们是课程就是整个机器学习
在量化交易的场景下的应用
所以机器学习
也是一个比较重要的部分
另外从数据获取分析处理
到我们从采样自定义轴的制作
到整个的趋势性标签的标注
再到我们的特征工程
然后再到数据降维
然后模型训练
然后再组合推理实盘交易
然后还有我们推荐的一些书籍和论文
也就是扩展阅读
因为这个部分
因为除了
基本上因为我看
那个大家基本上有的是
可能就觉得模型到训练的部分
可能就已经结束了
会认为其实不是那样的
因为在模型训练之后
还有很多的工作要做
比如说模型如何进行的组合
然后我们推理的时候
石盘推理的时候会有哪些的问题
其实也会要和大家要讲述
否则你模型训练完
你是没有办法用的
比如说你推理的问题
石盘交易中的问题
其实这个也是非常非常关键的
另外呢
就是我个人觉得呢
是国内现有的这个课程呢
基本上都是讲某一个环节
比如说一些规则类的方式啊
还有一些是跟因子相关
对
所以呢
这个我们的课程呢
是着重介绍整个的这个
Pipeline的整个生态线
这是最关键的
另外最重要的就是说是
每一个环节之间的这个关联性
这个可能我觉得是
对大家是最有用的一个部分
对
否则你只知道某一个环节
是如何去做的
其实意义并不是那么大
对
另外呢
我觉得这个不夸张的讲
基本上这些内容呢
基本上是国内唯一的
就是没有还没有哪一家机构啊
或者是个人把整个的这个pipeline
给大家全部的这个讲述出来
对
来实现这个
我们想完成的这个目标
也就是说希望大家通过我们的课程
能够实现完全自主独立的
然后进行模型的这个训练
以及实盘交易
这接下来呢
接下来呢
我简单的讲一下
我们课程上会涉及到的
一部分的内容
这个是机器学习的部分
因为我们会用到
其中的一些模型
对然后为什么用这些模型呢
这些模型有什么的优势
其实也是要要讲述给大家
对
然后这是其学习的这个部分
然后呢
另外呢
就是我们整个的这个对
这个航行数据的这个重采样
对
大家可以看到呢
右边是我们时间轴的这个概率分布
那左边呢
是我们自定义轴的一个概率分布
也就是说我们通过改变了重采样的方式之后呢
我们改变了它的概率分布的结构
那左边的这个我们自定义轴的这个轴
其实是更接近于正态分布的
我当然说课程上也会教大家如何实现
然后每一种计算方式都带来的是
每一种计算方式所带来的意义也是不同的
然后另外就是标签的部分
在这部分因为标签是一个乘上起下的一个部分
在这里边我们也是用到了机器学习模型的方式
去定义这个标签
可以针对我们不同的参数来调节趋势的大小
这是非常关键
也就是说我们可以保持
我们在周期不变的情况下
但是我们的把我们的标签的周期性变了
所以我们在周期不变的情况下
我们有很多很多的模型
它可以是低周期的
也可以是大周期的
对那方便我们后面用作模型组合
那这个也是比较特别的一个步骤
另外呢
标签的是整个模型里面乘上起下的步骤
因为你后面模型训练的时候
其实都在学习这个标签的这个特性
对所以这部分也是非常关键的
另外呢
就是说我们在所有的特征工程降维之后呢
然后我们会看到一个整个的一个结果
那这个呢
是我们做了
因为这个是之前我们公开课上会
公开课上讲到的一个内容
也就是说右边的这个部分呢
我们是用时间轴来实现
左边的这个部分呢
其实是我们是用自定义轴来实现
就是说大家可以看到左边的这个
包括收益啊
最大回撤卡码啊
包括回撤面积
其实要远远高于右边的这个时间轴的这种做法
那这个也是课程上需要大家来实现的
来复现的这部分
那这个呢
是我们刚才看到那个图上的这个复现完之后的
这个做完组合的这个
这个backtesting的这个结果
差不多是25个月吧
这是RB国内RB的这个数据
25个月然后收益呢是67.81
最大回撤呢是在这部分是5.78
卡码呢是因为超过5了
5.653
然后这个回撤面积
也就是说下面橘色的这个部分
的面积是23.46
但是说这个面积越小越好
越小的话其实就代表
我们的回补期是比较快
对那这个其实也是课程上
带着那个带着小伙伴
那个一起来复现
另外呢就是课程的内容呢
我们是分整个的是11个部分
包括这个机器学习的部分
其中呢有基础知识
然后模型的类别
应用的场景
包括我们如何应用在这个量化交易的这个场景中
然后呢就是我们的这个数据的部分
比如获取啊
分与分析
比如说海国国内和海外的这个数据的这个区别
包括我们一些时间轴的一些个问题等等
这个都会在这个部分详细的那个讲解
对
第三个部分呢
也就是说我们用做重采样的
自定义轴的实现的这个方式
那这里面呢
我们也会举两个比较经典的例子哈
然后让大家来实现
另外呢
我们也会在课程上讲一些
如何来实现接近于正态分布的
这个自定义轴的这个重采样的方式
对
第四部分就是刚才讲到
乘算起下的这个library标签的这个部分
这个呢
是我们会用到这个概率的这个模型
去整个的去无间度的去推这个表现
包括任何的条件的设定啊
包括一些那个参数的如何调节
这个都会在这个部分进行详细的讲解
那接下来呢
是特征工程的部分
特征工程的部分呢
我们会用非常经典的这个整数阶的
数据差分的方式来表达
对这个也是比较特殊的
对另外呢
我们会讲解一些常用的方式
以及就是说你在时间轴上
比如说因子啊
或者是你自己的
之前做过的一些因子
或者是特征如何用到这个
自定义轴上
所以这部分也是非常关键的
另外呢我们还会详细的讲商
因为之前我们公开课
其实也有讲过哈
但是这个正式的课程上
其实还更详细
也有具体的这个代码啊
也就是说整个的这个商
如何来表达这个强行的不确定性
那商务如何在特征工程中的一个应用
那这个也是我们特征工程里面
要重点要讲的内容
对
另外呢
第六部分就会详细的讲解
这个线性的这种数据降维的方式
以及非线性的这个
自变打气的方式的实现
那这个
因为这个可能数据降维的这个部分
正常情况下
可能很多小伙伴会用的比较少
其实这个也是非常关键的
也是防止我们过拟核的提前的一个工作
对因为我们没有在训练的时候
也就是说你在训练的时候要防止过拟核
那你在之前的其实每一步都应该进行过拟核的这种预防
那数据降维呢
其实也就是说减少我们更多项的这种数据高维下的这种约束
对所以呢
数据降维也是非常重要的一点
那在这里边呢
我们会讲解这个线性降维
与非线性降维的方式
以及一些就是在推理过程中
会遇到的这个问题
这个其实我们也是之前
碰到过这些石盘上的问题
对
然后呢我们也是在这个部分
其实是亏过很多钱
对
所以呢这部分也是
大家能够感受到
我们能够很多时候
把很多的石盘的经验
包括我们获利的经验
包括亏损的经验
都会告诉大家
让大家少走一些弯路
那第七个部分呢
也就是说我们整个的这个模型训练的这个部分
也就是说我们比如说用传统模型
凡是神经网络
那各自都有什么样的区别和优势
那我们模型训练出来
如何看它的结果
如何对比
对那如何防止过敏和
那其实也是这部分的重点要讲解
另外呢就是第八个部分
其实这个可能大家之前接触的比较少
就是说我们的这个模型
是不是具有专用性
或者叫通用性
举个例子
也就是说我们做
对一个标的进行模型的训练
那是不是我可以
把这个训练好的模型
用在其他的标的上
那其实这个就是牵扯到
你的模型的训练之后
是专用的还是通用的
那在这方面
我是觉得
我们也有蛮多的经验
可以用来分享
所以这部分
我们着重的是
讲解模型的通用性与专用性的这么一个问题
另外第九部分
我们是着重讲解的模型组合
比如说我们金融思维下模型是如何组合的
我们的数在数学思维下模型是如何组合的
也就是说组合以后我们会带来哪些的优势
或者叫潜在的风险
也就是说它可能是个双刃剑
他会带来会给我们带来一些不同的这种感受
包括我们是在因为我们是在自定义轴下面来做的这个模型的训练
以及是不是我们可以用不同趋势性的标签的训练出来的模型来进行组合
那为什么要这么来做
那其实在课程上也是要详细讲解的
那第十个部分的主要是讲这个我们石盘的这个模型的推理和石盘的这个交易
这个呢基本上我是觉得
这个其实还是蛮关键的
因为否则你模型训练完之后呢
你可能在推理的时候
在实盘的时候
可能会遇到很多的这个问题
因为模型不是说训练完之后就结束
那后面其实还有很多的这种工作
因为像我们在实盘的过程中
也会遇到很多推理上的一些个小问题
所以在这里边呢
我们也会把我们的很多的
这种实盘上的经验分享给大家
最后呢
这部分呢
就是这个扩展阅读的部分
然后我们也会给大家推荐一些
比较好的书籍
包括一些非常棒的这种论文
对这个我觉得可能是对大家后期的
一些个扩展性的学习
能够带来很多的这个帮助
另外呢
就是课程上
其实我们就是大家会
因为会跑这个代码
对所以呢
还是建议大家
建议小伙伴们会带着自己的这个笔记本电脑过来
当然说我们之前也碰到过
这个有小伙伴是直接抱着探视机来的
因为他他觉得可能会
那个你里面会不会有一些用到想法的这个地方
对其实都没关系
其实那个大家带带着那个笔记本电脑
其实就完全就足够了
另外呢
就是说之前也有小伙伴问
也就是说我们是有怎样的基础才能学这个课
其实坦率讲
比如说大家有一定的编程的基础
比如说学习过这个Python
对
然后呢
以及呢
对比如说统计啊
概率论的有初步的一些了解
其实就可以
因为我们课程上还是非常详细的
包括这个对内容的讲解
对这个代码的这个解读
都是非常详细的
对
OK
Uni
听不到
OK
现在可以了吗
一米老师
可以了
这样子的一米老师
那接下来呢
我就总结了一些
之前有问过咱们线下课程的小伙伴
就是大家比较关心的一些问题
然后呢
就您这边来给我们做一些解答
那像我自己呢
我之前也大概了解过
像目前咱们国内市面上量化相关的课程
就总结下来
其实就分为两类
一类呢
就是讲多因子挖掘的
那还有一类就是讲复现研报的
那一米老师像
其实我是非常清楚
像您有非常丰富的海外和国内的量化交易的经验
那对于像我们很多想要入门量化交易的小伙伴们来说
就究竟什么是最重要的
就是我们可以从哪一些方面去选择这些课程呢
其实客观来讲
量化交易本身其实是一个跨学科的
或者是叫非常体现综合能力的这么一个场景
然后其实量化最重要的
其实是你对整个的生产线的
工程上的这种全局观
也就是说你对整体工程的
统筹能力有多强
这个是非常关键的
也是我个人觉得是最重要的
就比如说我们要建一栋楼
或者是我们要盖一个房子
就是说你要先知道
怎么来打地级
以及比如说你怎么砌这个墙体啊
然后这个怎么施工啊
怎么预留一些这个什么接口啊
水电改造等等等等
对所以呢
就是也就是说
你需要对这个整体的这个流程
也就是说整个Pipeline的这个工程上
首先要有一个全局观
这个是最重要
就像刚才你提到的这个
比如说多因子啊
或者是什么四线延报啊
其实也不是说不重要
而是像这些内容呢
只是整个Pipeline
整个生产线中的一个环节
对
所以呢
大家如果把大量的时间都花在
某一个环节上面
其实对整体的这个盈利来讲的话
我个人觉得还是蛮难的
因为它没有这种全局观
对
它不知道如何乘上起下
不知道它的这个环节和前面和后面
是如何连接上
对
OK了解了
那像英明老师
像咱们的这个线下课程
其实就是
就究竟适合哪一些小伙伴们来听呢
其实我是觉得是更适合
就是将来会希望在这个
往这个职业量化方向发展的
这个小伙伴更适合一些
因为像之前很多听过咱们课程的
这个小伙伴
有的是在一些互联网的大厂
做这个算法工程师啊
然后完全都具具备很强的
这个IT的这个能力
对然后也有一些像海外
或者是国内的
嗯比如说像金融啊
数学之类的这些个嗯学霸
对然后呢他们呢
其实会在这个
比如说基础学科上面
能力会比较强
比如说统计啊
概率啊
数学方面
这个是他们的一些个优势
所以呢像嗯这些
比如说像是有大厂经验的
或者是这些海外
或者是国内名校毕业的小伙伴
其实他们在这个领域
做出来的这个模型
可能会更加的严谨
会更细腻
那当然其实也有一些
已经在私募大厂的一些个
比如说投研的小伙伴
或者是基金经理过来的
对
所以包括还有我们每次
基本上也都会有这个海外的小伙伴
比如说在海外正在上学的留学的
或者是海外私募机构的小伙伴
其实他们其实是比较适合这类小伙伴来听的
对那但是如果你对这个代码都可能都不太仔细
甚至完全不会用这个Python的小伙伴
那这个其实你是很难听懂的
另外还有一些完全做主观交易的
就是非常固化
它是可能不太能接受量化的这种方式
小伙伴我觉得可能就听下来会比较吃力
当然说你如果是主观想往量化的方向来转
同时你又有一些Python的代码的基础
我觉得是非常适合
OK好的
那一鸣老师
像我之前咱们很多听过课的小伙伴
其实我大部分我都认识
就大家都评价一鸣老师的课
就真的不夸张的说
大家都说真的是目前在国内能够听到顶级的课了
有的小伙伴就说
就是说课就是平时大家所
就是在研究的过程当中会遇到的一些问题
其实在课程上面他发现
有这么简单又巧妙的方法来解决
但这个简单大到至简
它肯定不是简单的简
对
然后就是大家会觉得
这个课程下来之后
它会站在更高的维度
去思考
去解决这个问题
那其实像一秒时
就我包括对跟平时
对很多量化改进去的小伙伴们
也交流
就是说大家会很关心的是
就是我听完这个课之后
它究竟能够给我带来
哪一些实质性的帮助
OK
实质性的帮助
其实我觉得是有几个方面
对我觉得第一个就是整体的课程
因为是给大家整个的
PAPLAN的这么一个系统性的工程
给到了大家
从数据的处理
成材样的自定轴
标签
特征工程
包括特征的重构
降维
比如说模型的训练
回测
组合
试盘推理等等
这中间有很多环节
因为每一步都会手把手的带着大家去跑代码
所以可以说是大家
从另外一个角度来讲的话
它就相当于是有了一条自己的模型的生产的生产线
或者叫工厂
你可以做出你想要的很多很多的这种海量的这种模型
而且是完全能够石盘落地
是可以去交易的
对
那无论你是在个人
还是在机构
想上规模的话
其实这个都是非常适合的
因为之前也有很多的
这个小伙伴也都拿到了
非常非常不错的这个结果
对
那当然也有说是
用这个整个PlanPlan
做成项目
去这个投这个一些
海外的这个机构的岗位
对
然后这个因为之前
我们也有这个海外的
这个小伙伴
对
另外呢
就说也有自己的这个
用自有的这个资金去交易
那无论是国内啊
还是这个海外的这个
然后这个收益还都还都是蛮好
其实这一点我是觉得还是
还是挺开心的
能够看到大家能够收获满满
对
另外呢
我是觉得就是
那整个他们生产下来的这个模型呢
其实与这个标的是无关的
对
因为整个的生产线的这个通用性会非常强
会非常强
那无论你是国内啊还是海外
你还是比如说商品期货啊
股指期货还是国内的ETF啊
还是海外的crypto
其实都是可以做的
那当然其实国内的个股是不建议做
因为个股其实不完全不具备统计特性
因为国内的ETF我们是建议做的
对
另外呢也就是说是
假设你有这个石盘经验的小伙伴
如果听完课的话
其实可能他的感受会更深
因为我们之前也有很多
有这些石盘的基础的小伙伴
然后可能他有很多的问题
或者叫困扰了很久的这个问题
就比如说
他们之前像是有走那个多因子的技术路线
然后呢
其实我们会给他一个不同的
这么一个技术路线给到他
也就是说机器学习的这个路线
其实它完全
可以抛弃掉之前的这种
技术路径的依赖
那在我们现有的这个Pipeline上
也可以有非常多的
扩展的空间
以及魔改的这个空间
对
所以这个也都是拿到了
非常不错的这个结果
对
另外呢最重要的是
我觉得整个的这个Pipeline
是Python我们是原生的
因为代码都是我们自己写的嘛
所以就是说是在整个的Pipeline串下来的时候
是完全不依赖于任何的第三方的平台
也就是说你完全是本地来运行
所以这种方式其实提高了你的代码的这种安全性
因为你没有依赖其他的第三方的平台
完全是本地
所以安全性是非常高
就像你刚才提的这个问题
就是说是小伙伴能够
就是通过课程能够学到什么
其实这个整体下来
这个就是我们能够给到大家
了解
那一鸣老师像我知道您是主要做海外市场
然后像咱们的其实很多方法论
都跟国内是不一样的
你比如说像数据处理
特征工程模型训练等等环节
就是方便咱们聊聊就是课程当中
有就是有具体区别于咱们目前国内的
一些那些主流的方式吗
国内的现在很多的交易方式
我觉得也都是蛮好的
但是其实我觉得最重要的
可能差别是在
更多的是在一些思维模式上
对我觉得这个差别还是蛮大
特别是我们看待
某一个问题的这个角度
对因为其实我身边很多的
同样是搞这种
比如说这个对冲基金的
或者是做交易的小伙伴
其实基本上都不是金融出身
对
所以呢
大家可能更能从不同的这种维度
不同的视角去看待一些问题
对
所以我是觉得
那我们在解决一些问题的思路上面
可能有更多的创新的方式
或者叫有更多的这种体系来解决
对
也就是说是可以把一些不同维度
不同视角的思维模式融入到
整个的生产线的设计和规划
同时呢也融入到了每一个环节
对
我觉得这个思维模式
可能是差别最大的一个地方
并且呢
其实我们都会非常喜欢
用混数学的方式来表达
或者是来解决很多的
现有的一些复杂的问题
对
那像我知道的
像国内大多数量化策略
其实比如像一些纯实序类的
也就是择取
或是像大家比较熟悉的多因子的策略
又或者是一些规则类的策略
就是还是大家在挖因子
或是主要在看一些技术指标
是在您的经验看来
就这些策略它本身会存在哪些问题
像你说的这些问题
其实之前也有很多小伙伴问过
它其实是一个普遍现象
对你就像比如说像多因子
那多因子的方式呢
其实最最严重的问题
其实就是因子的这种有效性飘移的这个问题
也也就说它是有时有效
有时没效
因为你也不知道它什么时候会有效
或者是没效
那如果是针对问题去解决的话
其实我觉得是很难的
所以我们需要换一个维度
或者是提高一个维度去看待
那比如说我刚才也讲到了
那我们课程上会讲到
如何抛弃时间轴
用我们重采样的自定义轴来做
那其实它呢
其实就是变相解决了
这个一部分因子的
这种有效性飘移的
这么一个问题
因为本身你的因子
可能就是在一个
不具有统计特性的时间轴上
来实现的
对那所以你的轴是有问题的
那你的因子的飘移
其实也是很正常
所以我想表达的是什么呢
就是说我们需要解决问题的时候
可能更多的需要换一个维度来
就是来思考
不能在这个就问题而解决问题
对
那所以呢
这个另外呢
就像我们平时处理数据的时候
也是一样
比如说我们对这个正常情况下
可能我们对数据降维完全是无感
但是其实往往呢
这种多因子策略
基本上你一股脑子都扔给模型的话
其实对它来讲
其实约束项态度
这个容易产生过拟合的这个风险
那所以我们课程上也会讲如何对特征重构
以及对如何进行
对模型进行这个线性
或者是非线性的这个降雷
OK了解
那其实一鸣老师的课我也听过好几次
因为我本身也是从机构出来的
我真的感受这套内容
目前国内最敢讲的吧
就是像我们很多
听过课的小伙伴们的
统一评价都是颠覆认知
原来还能这么玩
就是就真的是说实话
在国内目前能够听到的
最顶级的量化相关的课呢
但是其实说实话
有一个问题
也是大家其实蛮疑问的
就是一鸣老师
这个东西既然它能引力
那您这边为什么要
以这种课程的形式
分享出来呢
好问题
坦率讲因为从交易盈利的角度来说
其实因为我们本身海外的管理规模也还可以
另外主要是因为海外的限制
相对比国内的限制要更少
我们团队也是更成熟
更熟悉海外的市场
另外因为市场上的钱
你一家机构一个人是完全赚不完的
本身呢我个人其实也不是靠这个
讲课来谋生的
所以这个那
那当然后面呢
我们也会在国内有一些
布局的计划
但是完全是和这个
交易是没有关系
所以呢和这个国内的小伙伴呢
基本上没有什么冲突
所以呢我们也会愿意更
分享一些干货
其实也是通过这个过程
我觉得能够认识很多国内的
新的这个朋友
那在后面呢
可能我们会有更多的合作的这个可能性
对所以呢
那既然是这个大家的信任呢
来这个来听我的这个课程
其实也是不太想辜负大家
对所以会多讲一些干货
多讲一些真的东西
因为在这个行业
其实坦率讲很难撒谎
对因为你的这个内容好不好
因为大家都很聪明
你内容讲的好不好
然后是不是真东西
其实大家一听也都会知道
对另外呢
还有很多课程上非常多
本身是在大的机构里面
工作的小伙伴
所以呢
这个并不是说是简单的
讲几句就完全能够忽悠的
对所以必须要讲真东西
对这样的话呢
也是不辜负那个
不辜负大家对我的这个信任
是的
因为像我们每次课程结束后
就是我最喜欢的环节
就是听大家
就是聊这个课程之后的感受
因为大家的
就是大家的那种状态
让我就是特别的感动
因为我记得之前
有一个小伙伴说
他说量化研究本身是很孤独的
就像在黑夜里面行走一样
就很多时候
你可能一个技术问题
你可能卡住就是三五几个月
甚至更长时间
你在那个时候
其实是很无助的
就你身边哪怕是同事
其实大家都不太愿意分享经验的
没错没错
因为老师的课
我今天跟小伙伴原话的时候
他说就像黑夜里面的一盏灯
就是给大家活指明了一条走得通的路
是真的
就是很多时候自己做研究
可能真的就是抓瞎
抓瞎走
走到哪也不知道
可能很多时候也走进一个死胡同了
因为就还有
我记得之前有一个
哥大毕业的一个小伙伴
他说量化最残忍的真相就是
其实你在学校书本上学到的东西
其实是几乎都是没有办法落地转化的
所以我觉得其实这些
真的就都每次大家这么一聊
都让我觉得其实
就很感动
真的很感动
然后呢
当然其实也
就是这个其实也真的能理解
你看像我们
其实量化所有的经验
它都来自于真金白银大量的试错
所以其实也能理解
为什么在目前国内
几乎听不到真正有用的课程
第一个
大家都是竞争对手
第二个
我真金白银试错来的经验
我怎么愿意分享给我的对手呢
对吧
没错没错
你提的这个真的是一个非常客观的一个现象
对
然后其实之前咱们课程里也有很多小伙伴
也都是卧虎藏龙
对
然后呢
无论是这个私募的这个大厂的这个投研的人员呢
还是一些这个互联网大厂的这个搞算法的
其实说实话
很难独立的好出一套量化的生产线出来
对因为在成熟的机构里面呢
其实它每一个部门完全都是独立的
对然后其实你也非常熟悉
因为你之前也在大的机构也工作过
对然后就是它
就是你只需要负责好你自己的这个部门的
这个一个环节的工作就可以
那其他环节其实你完全没有这个机会来参与
另外呢是如果是站在机构老板的这个角度上来讲
其实他不太希望下面的这些个员工都
整个的这个环节他都学会
那否则你整个全学会了以后
那其实你就自己去单干就没有问题
所以像对一些这个刚拿到offer的这个小伙伴呢
或者是实习的小伙伴呢
其实他前期的工作基本上都很铺造
就是做一些非常简单的数据复理
挖因子之类的这种工作
是的
因为像我之前工作的公司
就是实习生的工作
基本上都是挖因子
那说到这里
一鸣老师
我记得咱们的课程
好像上完之后
都是可以免费复训的
对吧
没错
是
因为课程内容
其实还是蛮多的
因为像正常情况下
我们都是会在六日
然后六日两天
对
然后所以呢
大家课程结束后
也会花大量的时间去精力去消化
然后再去扩展
然后再去把整个的排布栏串起来
然后多做训练多跑通
对
所以在中间的时候
可能也会遇到很多问题
所以可以
比如说我们后期什么时候
有相应的课程的时候
他其实随时可以都过来听
对
另外呢其实每次那个也都是有这个问题解答的这个群哈
或者是直接加我个人的这个微信
比如说问我呀或者是问Uni其实都可以
对然后包括这个问问题包括这个复讯都是OK
OK了解了太好了
感谢英明老师的详细解答哈
那最后呢其实我想跟正在看这条视频的小伙伴们说
就英明老师的课程价值真的很高
但是一个班上老师再好
也会有学习成绩好和学习成绩不好的学生
所以大家如果真的要选择来听一米老师的课
也请一定要做好认真对待的准备
因为这套生产线是真的经过实践之后
是可以落地试盘的
所以像我们包括之前听过一米老师的课的小伙伴们
大家也都是拿到了结果的
像我们之前有小伙伴们做BTC和ETH的收益
其实都非常的惊人
这个真是不吹牛
因为圈子很小
所以就而且大家都做技术出身的人
有一说一哈
也不会就是一些什么太营销啊
怎么咱也不会
所以其实包括我很想对一些像
想要真正入门量化交易的小伙伴们
说句真心话
就一米老师的这一套内容
你要去踏踏实实的消化下来
就保守的时候
真的可以少走好几年的弯路吧
你看像我们之前有好几个
听过一米老师的小伙伴们说
他们前前后后听过的量化课程的学费
加起来有超百万的
这个是实话
真的一点都不夸张
就真的说实话
花那么多钱
还不如殷敏老师的这个课程来的实用
你甚至像我们咱们八月份
殷敏老师的进阶课
就真的是让我非常感动
就所有我们做的三期
所有报名进阶课的小伙伴们
都是在不知道课程大纲的前提下
就来听了
就是完全直接信任
这个现在不是新盲盒吗
连课程都有盲盒了
但是这个盲盒课
结果也的确没有让大家失望
对
对没错没错
有你这个你提到这个进阶课
这个真的其实还是蛮感动的
其实也是也感谢
也感谢那个大家的信任
对因为我们进阶课
首先的第一呢
是没有大纲
因为是为了保密
第二呢是这个完全不对外
只针对这个听过我们的这个
从数据到模型的这个拆解的
这个全过程的这个基础和小伙伴
然后才能上
对所以呢
这个内容呢
本身呢也是和这个
Uni的老师
然后呢也是我们之前在凯莱的同事
然后我们一起针对国内的这个市场
然后进行的这个重新设计的这个进阶课
这个真的很力量是非常高
所以呢课程开始前
我们完全的大纲都是完全保密
所以呢其实小伙伴也是在这个
完全不知道大纲的情况下
然后就是来报名来上
这个真的是感谢大家的这个信任
那最后我再总结一下吧
就是所有就是看视频看到这里的小伙伴们
就是一鸣老师的线下课程呢
主要讲的是整个一套的量化生量化系统生产线
就相当于是一个模型工厂
就是从数据处理到最后的示范回测啊等等
中间有非常多的环节
而且每一步都环环相扣
而且每一步都会有圆码交付
就整套整套生产线的设计也非常的灵活
它能够适配不同的标的啊的
就是大家的交易的个性化需求
就无论你是策略的构建呀
回测还是执行
就每一个环节都可以根据我们使用者的需求
进行自由调整
这个呢不仅提升了模型的应用范围
就是也让我们使用者在面对市场变化的时候
具备更强的应变能力
就是所有的这一切都是以实盘结果为导向
那所以说这个
就是也真的让移民老师的这套课程
这套生产线做到了真正的受人以鱼
就是最后呢
就是大家如果对移民老师的线下课程感兴趣的
可以联系我
那在这里呢
就祝大家的交易之路哈
所有小伙伴们
大鹏一日同飞起
扶摇之上九万里
那谢谢大家
那我们再见咯
谢谢尹老师
谢谢Uni
谢谢
谢谢再见
拜拜